the era of cheap money is not over but
it will soon be over we had we had what
has been aptly been called a global
savings glut that started in the middle
1990s and that his last until now and
it's been it has been driven it's been
driven a bubble by the extraordinary
economic rise of Asia so that people in
countries like India and China had much
more wealth than ever before combined
with extremely primitive and unreliable
financial systems in Asia so they had
more wealth and they didn't have good
places in which to put it and it was
very difficult for Asian societies to
tap the savings of their own country and
and so what we ended up doing was
accumulating a lot of savings in places
like central banks in these sovereign
wealth funds see you know once let me
start that again I'm Sergeant the era of
cheap money may may not be over but it
is going to be coming to an end we had
in the 1990s more savings worldwide then
there are good places in which to put
savings and and that there was immediate
demand for consumption with this huge
accumulation of wealth in Asia and China
and India coupled with very poor
institutions in places like China and
India for people to save their money now
what is going to be happening is as the
planet ages we are going to shift from
being a planet of workers and savers to
being a planet of consumers and we are
we are going to find that there are more
and more demands for the accumulated
wealth as we have to pay the pensions
not just a whole aging Americans and not
just of aging European sort of aging
Chinese I mean China is also a rapidly
aging Society they're going to be huge
demands on medical care not everybody in
the world is going to is going to be
able to pay for their own medical bills
but governments are going to step in and
so we are going to be moving into an era
in which capital having been very
abundant is going to find it's got all
kinds of new demands
form of immediate consumption when you
are 40 what you are presumably doing if
you're making good decisions is
consuming less than you earn because
you're going to get old you may get sick
your children to raise so you earn a
certain amount and you consume rather
less and what also then happens is you
get taxed and that and if your
government is doing its job right it is
not immediately consuming everything it
taxes it is also finding ways to put
that toward investment whether not
government should meet whether putting
it in trust funds for future pension
claims putting in enough roads and
bridges that does also represent wealth
they contribute to the society's ability
to create wealth in the future now
you're 70 when you're 70 you are almost
certainly consuming more than you are
because you've reduced your work effort
and your demands are you not only do you
need a pension but through through your
demands on the health care system who
are probably consuming more a society
where the center of gravity were there a
lot of a lot more 40 year olds then
there are 70 year olds is going to be
saving more than it consumes a society
in which the proportion of 70 year olds
is growing rapidly is going to be one of
the consumes a lot more than it's able
to save well every country in the
developed world and many in the
underdeveloped world are going to be
looking more like countries of 70 year
olds and then your future than there are
countries of 40 year olds and that is
true not just in the United States not
just in the developed countries between
China as well
what it means is that he remains it
means that if you are Union and if
you're a union in Norway and your
members paid use you have been
presumably taking those serving what
does it mean mean if you're if you're a
Norwegian pension plan your members have
been contributing till now more than
they need to receive in return and
you've been taking their contributions
and you've been looking for investments
all over the planet and every year you
are buying more investments then you are
paying out in benefits because most of
your members of your pension plan are in
their 40s now fast forward to world
world in which most of the members of
your pension plan are in their 70s each
year they're going to be cashing out
more from the pension plan than they're
paying in so if you're a Norwegian
pension plan in 1995 you are buying more
than you were selling if you're a
Norwegian pension plan in 20-25 you will
probably be selling more than you are
buying and so whereas in the 1990s you
had a lot more savings than there were
business opportunities and so interest
rates were low in the 2020s they're
going to be a lot more business
opportunities than there are savings
you